kommen wir nun zur immer beliebten
kategorie überraschungen die gar keine
sind
echt jetzt die deutsche polizei hat ein
rassismus problem
gibt's doch nicht gibt's leider wohl in
essen wurden 30 polizisten gerade
suspendiert die in chat gruppen über
jahre widerwärtige rechtsextreme hetze
ausgetauscht haben ja und danach musste
sogar der nrw-innenminister herbert reul
zu geben dass das problem ja doch
irgendwie größer ist als von ihm erhofft
ich habe gehofft dass wären einzelfällen
erinnern sich ja daran aber inzwischen
ist mir klar das sind nicht nur einzelne
fälle erst haben danach jetzt muehlhan
das ist zu viel das ist mir zu viel
jetzt wird's mir doch zu viel wenn ich
den typ fass der für diesen saftladen
zuständig ist ach was bin ich
die suspendierten 30 waren mal fast eine
komplette woche in mülheim an der ruhr
warum mussten die redner bilder posten
könnte man auch einfach über den
schreibtisch reichen york manfred hitler
selbstverständlich ist das nicht die
deutsche polizei und es ist schlicht
großartig wenn wie hier beamte aus allen
abteilungen der polizei gelsenkirchen
mit so einem gruppenfoto ein klares
zeichen gegen rechts setzen
natürlich steht der großteil der
deutschen polizei fest auf dem boden
unseres grundgesetzes
da aber aktuell 400 verdachtsfälle von
rechtsextremismus rassismus und
antisemitismus bei polizei und
polizeianwärtern aktenkundig sind könnte
man doch mal erforschen wie groß das
problem genau ist es gibt bisher keine
richtige strukturelle studie dazu und
bundesinnenminister seehofer will noch
nicht mal eine rassismus racial
profiling studie in der deutschen
polizei zu lassen warum nicht ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob das was bringt wenn
wissenschaftler jetzt einfach mal nen
untersuchung auch so eine sache wir
brauchen fakten
wir brauchen keine wissenschaft wir
brauchen fakten andererseits ich meine
wer will schon studien die nur schlechte
laune machen
da legte herr rolf vollauf seehofer
linie ist quasi einer von den zeugen
jehovas im juli hat der horst unser
innenminister eine studie zum racial
profiling einfach mal eingestellt
altersstarrsinn ich habe keine ahnung
wenn er wirkt ja insgesamt gerade wenn
sie darauf achten irgendwie
angeschlagenen meiner meinung so wie
hier als er auf das thema flüchtlinge
angesprochen wird
was wäre ihre botschafter in österreich
und die österreicher beginnen
da wird mir sprachlos in österreich
regieren auch die grünen die grünen die
grüne horst können wir dich lieber mal
um die braunen selbst cdu kollegen sagen
inzwischen sondern studie zu rassismus
bei der polizei wäre gut gerade für die
übergroße mehrheit der anständigen
polizisten seien zum beispiel auch der
bund deutscher kriminalbeamter meine
spätes der fall essen oder mülheim hätte
seehofer doch aufrütteln müssen warum
bleibt ja so seltsam entspannt viele
innenminister liegen nachts wach weil
immer mehr fälle von rechtsextremismus
bei ihrer polizei ans licht kommen
daran kann man nichts ändern aber man
kann drogen nehmen
scheißegal forte mit natürlichen opium
und heroin extrakten blendet hässliche
wahrheiten einfach aus scheißegal forte
weniger wissen müssen
[Musik]
meistens sind drogen eben doch die
lösung
seehofer hält eisern an seiner
einzelfall theorie fest ja es gibt recht
die polizisten aber das sind alles quasi
heinzelmännchen ja ganz schön viele
einzel männchen wenn was hatten wir da
nicht alles polizeiwagen mit aufkleber
der identität in bewegung oder mit dem
reichsadler sitzkissen mit solchen
schicken symbolen hier umgedrehte
flaggen vor einer polizeiwache
rein zufällig am holocaust-gedenktag
einzelfälle alles einzelfälle
und wenn sie jetzt denken dass man wegen
so was direkt raus fliegt dann kennen
sie aber das deutsche beamtenrecht
schlecht wird so einfach wäre beispiel
bei einem berliner polizisten der mit
nazi tattoos geradezu übersät war und
der öffentlich beim hitlergruß gesehen
wurde hat es trotzdem zehn jahre
gedauert den zu feuern denen aus dem
dienst zu entfernen
experten fordern seit jahren eine
anonyme meldestelle für whistleblower
bei der polizei denn sich beim
vorgesetzten beschweren beendet da gerne
mal karrieren stichwort chorgeist hier
ein ehemaliger polizeischüler wie zum
beispiel situation wo wir beim
schießtraining waren und der schieß
lehrer gesagt wir müssen wieder gut
schießen lernen also viele geflüchtete
nach deutschland kämen und an silvester
kam es dann eben auch dazu dass ich mal
eine sehr rassistische äußerung
geschrieben hat mit ja wir sind aus
cottbus und nicht aus ghana wir hassen
alle afrikaner oder wie wäre es mit wir
sind deutsch und zwar zur gänze haben
alle kleine hirne oder so kollegen die
nazis bei der polizei melden sind eben
keine verräter sondern demokraten und
wir regeln das lieber intern heißt du
sonst nur bei kriminellen clans oder
natürlich bei der katholischen kirche
schon beim aller ersten
vorstellungsgespräch für den
polizeinachwuchs muss man irgendwie
versuchen rechtsextreme zu erkennen der
verfassungsschutz wird in den
polizeibehörden einfach ein stück
aufklärung liefern weil ich glaube viele
wissen gar nicht welche zeichen welche
symbole welche kleidung indiz für sowas
sind genau wer weiß das schon
woher wir das wissen hier ganz schwere
aufgabe aus dem einstellungstest für den
gehobenen polizeidienst in nordrhein
westfalen
hat man nur 30 minuten zeit das
verbotene symbole anzukreuzen richtig
der penis geht gar nicht penis geht gar
nicht seehofer beharrt darauf kein
bedarf an einer rassismus studie bei der
polizei wählen sagt er dann für die
ganze gesellschaft und er bleibt beim
komischen einzelfall mantra ich fürchte
meine damen und herren
der mann braucht einzelunterricht
telekolleg durch methodische und
schwerer alexander wipprecht
so horst handy wegzuhören einzellfall
hauptwort laut wikipedia ein einmaliges
vorkommnis das sich nur mit geringer
wahrscheinlichkeit in derselben form
wiederholen wird
verstehst du aus wie viele fälle
bräuchte ist du denn damit kein
einzelfall besten 2007 auch auf schreibt
meine fresse 71 und immer noch der
klassenclown post niemand stellt die
polizei unter generalverdacht niemand
was denkst du denn wer daran ein
interesse hätte die grüne und nein auch
nicht die grünen wenn eine große zahl
von nicht deutsch aussehen den
mitbürgern den umfragen sagt sie haben
angst vor der polizei dann haben wir ein
problem punkt und hör auf abzulenken ja
rassismus gibt in der ganzen
gesellschaft aber bei bestimmten berufen
ist es halt schlimmer als bei anderen
beispiel keine ahnung rechtsextremer
förster ist nicht schön hat aber für die
gesellschaft keine direkten auswirkungen
außer dass er vielleicht andere bäume
pflanzt oder so zum beispiel oder sagen
wir mal nazi tierpfleger im zoo geht
nach afrika
nervig für die tiere aber ich sag mal
kein drama polizisten ganz anderer
schlag ist hier die haben das
gewaltmonopol und sind bewaffnet
deswegen hausaufgabe bis montag erstmal
um rechte bei der polizei kümmern danach
kommen die anderen branchen reinbeker
postboten yogalehrer nur fernsehen
kannst du weglassen hier beim
öffentlich-rechtlichen arbeiten in
linksextreme
was haben wir was steinen schmeißen
gesagt als maul kapitalisten schweiz
[Musik]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
los los du scheiße fährt haye